participer à la ryder cup sans être
tiger woods c'était possible ce week end
grâce à la fan zone avec en plus
d'animations gratuites et surtout la
retransmission en direct sur écran géant
des matches
la fan zone a eu pour objectif pendant
trois jours de faire découvrir aux saint
quentinois la ryder cup hier pour la
première journée de la femme zone
il y en a eu huit mille personnes donc
c'était un superbe journée mais c'est
parfait et aujourd'hui un petit peu
moins de monde mais le public reste plus
longtemps il ya de beaucoup de familles
il ya des personnes qui viennent
signifier des personnes qui
connaissaient pas du tout le golfe et
des personnes qui viennent soutenir les
équipes sont en europe ce soir états
unis quatre espaces d'animation gratuits
ont ainsi permis aux visiteurs de se
plonger dans l'ambiance avec notamment
un espace dédié aux plus petits ou
encore un parcours découverte permettant
de visiter le golf national à 360 degrés
grâce à la réalité virtuelle
ça permet de promouvoir un peu le golfe
et ça fait découvrir aux enfants pour
les miens en tout cas un sport que fait
leur faire donc on trouve ça plutôt
sympathique pour les zones initié pour
moi ils ont misé déguster transat pour
regarder tranquillement ce qui se passe
au son grand écran non c'est pas mal on
a la possibilité de se réunir en un lieu
qui est déjà bien connue de tous les
saint quentinois
donc c'est toujours un bon moment de
convivialité ça nous rappelle il ya
quelques mois ses fans zone qu'on avait
pour le foot aussi
donc c'est encore des grands moments de
plaisir qu'on partage c'est super durant
ces trois jours plus de 15000 personnes
sont passées à la fan zone et le public
c'est bien sûr donné rendez-vous en
nombre dimanche soir pour le match final
europe etats unis